an msnbc guest goes on tv
and compares the republican party to al
qaeda
the majority of people in this party and
their elected leadership
is siding with the anti-democratic
forces within the republican party
it's not that it's just a segment of the
party it's not becoming
the entire party i don't think there are
enough of people who are willing to
stand up
to this iteration of the republican
party to build another party at this
point i mean
for all of the conversation about liz
cheney or mitt romney or adam
kindergarten
they're the outliers and it's really
it's really something hearing those
comments from
president george w bush i've been
thinking to myself this whole time you
know
al qaeda osama bin laden the taliban
the people who wanted to do harm to our
nation and to our way of life in our
democracy
they got nothing on what this republican
party is doing
the idea that a member of their party of
their leadership whose last name is
cheney
could be purged from their leadership
for telling the truth about january 6
for telling the truth about a violent
insurrection that claimed the lies
of among a capital police officer
the republican party according to this
msnbc guy
is far more uh
of a threat to the america that he
envisions
than al-qaeda al-qaeda
ain't got nothing on these guys he says
obviously
an outrageous and inflammatory statement
but i'm and this guy doesn't know
anything about anything he's pulling the
same the usual tactic of
i you know look i love liz cheney i love
george w bush they're all the
republicans that lose and hate the
republican party
and are now attacking the party and
supporting the democrats i really
support them i have a strange new
respect for them so he's pulling that
thing whatever it's a sort of
stupid political rhetorical device but
people use it on his point though
i want to give it the most charitable
read possible
i think he's actually has a little bit
of a point
this msnbc guy
believes that the republican party
is has is far more transformative
for the uh country than al qaeda or
osama bin laden or something like that
he's absolutely right in this sense
what did osama bin laden and the taliban
and the people who
launched the attacks on 9 11 do they
killed thousands of innocent americans
this was
this was the worst bloodiest most
terrible attack
in american history yes
it did not succeed at what it attempted
succeeded in killing people but it did
not succeed at the ideological goal of
totally changing the direction of the
country
actually what happened is we just kind
of kept up the same policies that we
already had we ratcheted them up a
little bit but the the liberal
internationalism
uh that we saw with george h.w bush and
that you saw
to a lesser degree with bill clinton and
you see with george w bush and you see
it with
with obama that just kind of continued
to pace
in fact we restarted a war that we had
already won in the early 90s we actually
just went right back to what we were
doing before
whereas this republican party that msnbc
has such a big problem with
this republican party is
threatening that liberal establishment
the liberal establishment that actually
goes back further than george h.w bush
you see the kind of seeds of this
progressivism
in the during the cold war certainly
after world war ii
and on the domestic front even going
back further than that in franklin
roosevelt and even all the way back to
woodrow wilson
this republican party right now is
questioning that is actually threatening
that
was there really much of a difference
between bill clinton and george w bush
and george h.w bush and barack obama
there wasn't a huge difference
what there was was uh you know a
little change on the margins but then
trump comes in and he says actually all
you guys are wrong on foreign policy
all of you you all have the same foreign
policy and you're all wrong all you guys
are wrong on trade
you all have basically the same trade
regime and it's totally wrong
all you guys are wrong on manufacturing
you're outsourcing that's totally wrong
all you guys are wrong on immigration on
some of the most important issues
you guys are totally wrong
so
because of this the left you know
they'll say nice things about george
bush or liz cheney right now
because the real threat to them the real
threat to their vision of the country
are all those trumpy type of republicans
the msnbc guy is using outrageous
disgusting inflammatory rhetoric but the
point he's making i think is actually
pretty fair
all right that was a fun wait a second
don't nope not just yet
ring that bell subscribe make sure you
get notifications
i can't believe i almost got out of this
chair without you have to do it
or you won't be able to see our videos
see you next time
[Music]
you